[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
happy wednesday and welcome back to the
break room this is our daily live show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know live from our very
own break room here at new rockstars hq
uh coming up on the show today chris
hemsworth looking weird what what
happened what happened someone fixed my
boy
jason momoa is entering a new villainy
era
it's very interesting uh and also king
kong more like ding dong disney plus
you ever play that as a kid
disney plaza yeah you go
run run to your computers and go to
disney dollars yeah your favorite disney
villain
yeah all of those are correct uh and of
course we've got our she-hulk
predictions uh we've got our she-hulk
fantasy league going coming back this
week baby
tommy sitting on the board with zero
points yeah uh
we're gonna make our predictions today
because the episode comes out tonight
and we're super excited who's super
excited you might ask well i'm brandon
and joining me on the show today we got
koi jondro
hey it's gonna be back i'm so excited
i'm back in the building this time today
uh we also have jessica clemens oh
seductive you know me the sexiest person
here joking we're all sexy what uh that
seems like a cop-out answer
and right next to me yeah you know me i
love him tell me back to him keep it
gucci to mochi baby
so positive this wednesday mm-hmm
uh we've also we're running our
redemption today uh and for every
hundred dollars that we raised in the
super chats we're gonna hulk out baby uh
because we got hulk coming out she-hulk
attorney at law coming out tonight and
we're super excited so we'll hulk out we
gotta we got a bucket of topics don't go
out on you know you know we got a little
rage uh built up inside of us traffic's
always bad it's hot it's hot in this
area
of the country it's hot all over the
world because of climate change that's
our first topic today folks oh wow i
have a lot to talk about
who's got thoughts on it uh hey if
you're watching the show hit the like
button go ahead and do that join us on
our discord where you can have lots of
fun conversations to make clips of the
week send in voicemails all that good
stuff but we have so much to talk about
today it's a big day lots of news coming
out so let's get to
the headlines
headlines
first headline uh
uh it's it's this is such fresh news
that our poor graphics department all 16
of them they didn't have time to put
together a graphic for it so there's no
lower third you're gonna have to listen
to the sound of my voice or turn on that
cc on youtube that works so well
uh the warner brothers discovery has
announced new release dates for some of
their upcoming dc films and you won't be
surprised to hear that these dates are
further away
okay not close to the old uh release
date shuffle folks shazam exclamation
point fury of the gods is now delayed to
march 17th oh come on
that's right you'll celebrate is that
same patrick's day it's i think it's in
the same
day confirmed so i'll be blackout in
shazam yeah
after i leave the first one was like
another straight hair the first one was
a christmas movie maybe this one is now
a st patrick's day i support these
underage children getting very
when they should stand up they can drink
whatever they want that's true
they can drink whatever and he does you
know hey if you're old enough if you're
old enough to defend the planet you're
old enough to drink that's what i say
south america
makes sense
that's what i say uh
this this movie so shazam fear of the
gods was originally supposed to come out
december 21st 2022 uh and as noted
cameron file john costar producer
pointed out that is the release date for
avatar two
it's back folks uh so do you think they
got a little scared do you think the
guys are too scared so apparently the
original release date was three months
after mark 16 had put it at june and
then they moved it up six months yeah
now it like hit that metal you say
original you mean like back
yeah when they were planning shazam two
we were all spinning each other's mouths
because we'd never heard of coping right
now
they were planning for it to come out
june 2023 apparently and then they moved
it up substantially i think to parallel
it with black atom and now they've moved
it away because of avatar and i think
it's an imax thing because you only have
like one imac screen oh so that's a good
point if that guitar is taking up its
imax you're not going to want to be you
know have that issue
we
yeah uh dominance at the box office but
he's coming back he's re-releasing
avatar for this somehow somehow james
cameron has returned somehow
he should be in avatar too he better
begin he better have a cameo yeah he'll
be mad if he's not one of those blue
boys running around one of the whales
he did all the mocap for the whales
uh now they've also moved the date the
release date for aquaman and the lost
kingdom which is now delayed to december
25th christmas day oh 2023. this movie
was supposed to come out march 17th 2023
when shazam is now captured
also i think this movie is done right
okay
substantial amount of affleck i think
they they implied it's a little affleck
i think it's going to be a lot of
affliction this movie has michael keaton
at all was he involved in this not
anymore i don't know
i'm wondering i think everybody's cheats
is out
it's gonna be really interesting if we
ever find out the sheer volume of keaton
that has been addressed the keaton
server is well protected and tucked away
somewhere but it's interesting because
you've got shazam which is you know a
young cast right these kids gonna be
driving these kids are gonna be voting
these kids are gonna be drinking
everything they're growing too fast
if you want to use them like stranger
things all over again well when they
tried to make those chronicles of narnia
movies oh they had our time like
taking them years to fill them it didn't
matter to me i was like oh they're still
kids i love that shazam too i mean
shazam's my mouth i think might be my
favorite dc film like of the voice and
so i was really excited for this one i'm
really curious how the tone change will
affect the greater dc eu because if it
does well i think they stay with this
disparate universe right but this one
remember that trailer advertised the
shared stuff whereas the first film
didn't feel like it was in the universe
this one does like they showed clips of
flash they showed batman they showed all
these yeah versus the first movie that
was like we're not going to show
superman no just this body i'm curious
if they're putting it you know i mean
like maybe they use that time to kind of
ah total shift i don't know i don't know
well
you know
i guess tracy mobile's got some free
time doesn't have a presence
he's pretending to be a flight attendant
giving his
we've all been fed that sponsored
content uh
uh yeah i don't know good luck guys good
luck uh i just feel bad i feel like
aquaman two is ready to go and now we
gotta wait somewhere and they've
screamed shazam too like i hear it's
tested well so i'm like come on okay i
don't know we're ready you know it
worked out well for morbius i think it's
gonna work here folks this is some other
fresh news some other real fresh news
and this is this is how the news affects
our real life wow
koi was almost late today because of
some insane superhero vandalizing well i
should say superhuman i'm not gonna call
her a superhero super human vandalizing
going around around los angeles this is
real let's let's take a look at this
footage
uh if your kids were watching they might
have to explain what that word is maybe
you just heard it and she flipped them
off and obviously that was the edited
version of a very graphic song yeah
so uh jamila jamel has been going around
la today as titania uh tagging she-hulk
billboards and putting over uh like
stencils and putting over her own poster
you know just uh making it all all real
life uh but you were kind of the traffic
did you yeah so like basically there was
a bunch of people crowded around stuff
and then by the time i got there i had
seen the remnants of the just things so
i was like and then i saw the clip and
went oh that's why i was stuck so i
retroactively got to be stuck by a
superhero welcome to l.a
oh there that is that makes sense if you
haven't seen uh if you haven't seen it
before and maybe you're a fan of james
corden if you are please leave the
country all right
but he used to famously do a little uh
they would do little musicals in the
street you can find footage of people
stuck in traffic when he's doing that
i got a little los angeles
they don't like that kind of stuff no
this stuff happens all over our lives if
it's something i want like i've uh my
friend was stuck in the cinderella one
the amazon cinderella remake and she was
like if it was bts harry styles anyone
else i would have been like oh my god
you said it was corden going crotch deep
on some people's windshields what i
think is that shield breaks the fourth
wall and it's a show much like amazon's
the boys where it's like you've got ads
for superhero stuff and i feel like i'm
in that universe because the billboards
and like the benches and then today i
was very literally yeah
and then here we are wow what a universe
what's real anymore what's what is weird
in six months what is the construct
everything's a lie
uh okay
next headline
lord of the rings rings of power uh has
some early reactions coming out from
people have seen the show and they're
saying that it is a breathtaking
spectacle that's getting some like
positive news they put out a new trailer
yesterday it's like two and a half
minutes uh and it looks very interesting
i i think this is like this is amazon's
response to the good news around house
of the dragon having like a big premiere
day relatively positive news uh this
this whole show is gonna happen
inside of house of the dragon yeah it's
a it's a little cruise missile hitting
the bunker of house of the dragon trying
to explode it from the inside the you
know it's it's starting after house of
dragon already started but it's going to
wrap up before house of the dragon is
over wow they want you to have a lot of
fun inside of it i mean the trailers
showed
a ton of different vistas and all these
like species and all this stuff from the
second age and uh i think that's it's
interesting they compare that to what
house of the dragon is now where it's
like it's a world we've already seen
before and it's way less of that world
that's like the main criticism that show
i think has had in its first episode
where it's like well i miss going around
and seeing
a snowy place and a sandy place in a
watery place now we're just at this one
castle with this one family i think
we're divesting deeper right like we're
gonna get to know them i think one of
the criticisms of game of thrones was
that once it got so broad it was like
what's going on plus we'll have that
with this because we get to hone in and
hopefully care more yeah uh without
peter dinklage having so quotable but i
do think that the amazon is
intentionally going broad while that
goes like more niche and the violence
like you know i'm not as worried about
about kids you know seeing some
castration on the amazon yeah yeah yeah
it's funny that you're like on amazon
but it's like yeah but the boys walked
into a pizza
uh well we teased it at the top of the
show it's our next headline too uh chris
hemsworth he's hideous now folks uh oh
god i don't know what's happened to him
he just looked like a character out of
like the hunger games please uh there's
been a picture release of chris
hemsworth on the set of mad max furiosa
exclamation point here it is
uh
this looks like he's a mr mcgorm's
wondering like a character from the
grinch it kind of looks like chris pine
i think he draws he kind of smells like
chris pine in here can you play with
that
i think he looks great it's great it's
so good i like that you can't see his
costume you just see the north shore
did you see free guy with ryan reynolds
because he looks like seth rogen's
character oh yeah yeah yeah that's uh
that picture will be up on americana at
brand memes today guaranteed as like
silver lake guys or gotta be pickle park
boys or something
uh that's a guaranteed book it if you're
watching americana at brand memes you
can have that one uh
yeah we're all excited about furiosa
it's been i don't know we know
production has been stopped twice at
this point for copenhagen uh which is
tough because they're such a practical
movie they need a lot of uh people on
set and all that and the new george
miller films out this weekend right the
five thousand years of yeah yeah
waiting what is it about that reading
wanting andre selva's in it yeah yeah
tilda swinton's in it um yeah yep
second weekend yeah i like it i like it
i'll go see uh dragon ball super for the
third time
all right next headline uh jason momoa
is teasing his fast fast 10 uh fasten
your seat belts
as
quirky and androgynous he had a very
interesting quote where he said i've
never played a character that's what's
the word he's evil and quirky and
androgynous uh he explained that his
character is very sadistic and fun it's
very bizarre
that's a lot of that's a lot of it's all
right it's a lot of descriptors okay uh
and i think him kind of uh
backasting him his way into androgynous
is interesting like yeah do you know
what this character is i don't know but
it does sound like it's gonna be a very
fun character for him i think for him
yeah he's gonna have it to bring this
character to the screen because
yeah i mean he gets typecast as like a
big muscly
he's throwing axes drinking pints but
maybe this time he's putting a little
eyeliner on putting the pantyhose yeah
yeah he's a david bowie out there or
something i know that i don't know we
just found the club very funny yeah very
really
such a long way and i just i'm my
biggest fear is i'm like yeah i don't
mind that it's more so i'm like can fast
and the furious deliver this this is
gonna be like a michael bay way of
handling this one that's where i'm like
played for jokes androgyny yeah well
it's gonna be interesting in a movie
that's so big everything's at 11. like
how do you do that
out of a ten part one and two this is
ten years this is ten points
my children call you uncle dwayne come
back finish what we started here back to
the show i don't have the best time ever
at comic con i'll read this dwayne
all roads lead
to this
just quotes all the time
whatever you want as long as it's a
corona
on this set
next
headline right
guys king kong is getting another is
getting a live action series uh it's
currently in development at disney plus
now this we this was interesting to us
because this is not related at all to
the warner brothers discovery king kong
or godzilla monster verse so this this
isn't even like 2005. no no this isn't
related to the peter jackson one either
it's not related to any king kong this
is a new king kong it was beauty who
killed the base
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's climbing the empire state building
that's way too tall
he's gonna fall down from that i bet i
reckon he can't climb that hill he's got
a blonde down get out of here sir get
out
we need you out of the area he's got a
lady in his arms
oh hi sweet
oh he's got a beautiful blonde lady in
his eyes someone please pick this man up
and get him away from the area love is
real
yeah
i can't why are they making this i don't
know this is for this
i want to narrate it
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
ruled
the universe
yeah this is just like a new
our legal expert on the show uh zach
cuddleston yes he was saying that this
has a lot to do with like the copyright
of king kong yeah because there's a book
there's the movie stuff which like kind
of universal owns uh and like warner
brothers and then there's like the
novelization there's the novel that
kingdom is based on which has to be fair
game now yeah the number of years yes
so like you can just you can make a
thing about the jungle book if you want
it's like there's a jungle book movie
we should make dracula that's why they
do that all the time that's why they do
tarzan why not
it is gonna be interesting because uh
universal even the park is like king
kong king kong
young no i'm over it now i don't like it
anymore now come on it doesn't work on
me anymore sit on my lap and i'll tell
you a story let me bridge your hair
get them away from me give me a chance
to breed your hair brandon hey brandon
i just want a big ape to put me in his
hands and climb a building
uh
uh a reminder that we're hulking out
today for every 100 days of the super
chat and we do appreciate your super
chats out there we certainly do david
henry bennett sent one in very early
just getting on on air uh uh he says he
sent several super chats what a flex
from my guy let the people out there
know y'all are wonderful you make my day
i also want a real musical in the mcu
there are many musicians in the mcu they
can do it i mean if they don't make
uh roger's the musical a real thing yeah
yeah which they were uh put it in the
park put it at
california adventure you got nothing
going on at the hyperion stage right now
it's right next to the avengers campus
we don't want the frozen show back let's
let's do well just a musical you can
make it a tight 20 minutes cycle at
least eight eight shows a day it'll be
great when it comes to the frozen show i
think they should
let it go
when it comes to our chat i want zach
not fighting people in it ah
zach get film juice get his ass does
that is that causing problems with the
child film juice is a menace
next headline next headline uh michael
pena addresses uh his possible aunt
ant-man 3 return he was asked if he's
coming back and he replied quote who
knows uh when he was further asked about
if he could say anything about it he was
like uh you can't yeah of course i don't
even know why people ask which is you
know true they can't say anything right
i feel like is it just in like uh now
journalists just have to ask that
question but it's like we all know right
yeah yeah
i think i we were saying that t.i and uh
david delmashian david i'm actually not
gonna they said they're not they're not
as far as we know
oh it's like i think that studios or not
the people making it but the the
journalist studios want them to hope
they slip but then it's still wasting
everyone's time right then by the time
it comes out then it's like okay yeah so
i mean i feel bad for michael peen you
have to be creative every like yeah
interviews but he's probably in it i
feel like this this movie is going to
have a lot less like in real world stuff
anymore in the past
what i think we need is the 12-year you
know summary of the mcu by michael payne
like that's what i want i want them to
really write down i want him to sit down
with kang review where we've been and
check the whole script i like it
sorry i keep going uh someone's breaking
into the cars outside okay uh if it's
you please stop you guys also hit that
like button stop stop making people
fight in the chat uh
but i do i get behind zach versus tommy
any day no
no
i would never fight zach he doesn't want
to please me mate
he's my best friend he doesn't want me
to exactly he's my cell brother that's
that way he's my sweet cheese
has revealed that she hulk reached 1.5
million u.s households no way samba tv
reported in the first four days now if
you are like don lee and you can't
believe that samba tv has this news uh
they're they kind of work like a nielsen
box it's like a voluntary thing they
like did a partnership with disney so
they've kind of done the numbers for
disney before so these are just what
soundbit tv is saying which is probably
what disney has allowed them to say uh
which is why they did a partnership with
them and don't just like let neilson
handle it uh so they said for example
that like she-hulk had 1.5 million and
this was for the first four days these
other numbers i don't know if it's the
first four days like the first weekend
because they came out on different days
but loki had 2.5 million which makes a
lot of sense i was very popular i had
the biggest name you know tom hiddleston
being and it was big moon knight had 1.8
million falcon winners soldier also had
1.8 million one division had 1.6 million
and hawkeye had 1.5 million so it's
right there in the middle uh
like the lowest according to all them
yeah this is through sunday right it's
through sunday yeah it's thursday
through sunday i don't i can't say if
all of those are four day totals because
remember loki was coming out on like
friday
they moved loki to wednesday i think
that's when they first started joining
wednesday
we were fridays
we're friends yeah so yeah
so there you go you learn something new
every day don't you stay in the accent
oh you learn something new every day uh
and finally one more headline i promise
just one more headline uh she-hulk
director kat koi ro has teased more mcu
cameos
she she said i think the idea that we
are in this world where the superhuman
law firm exists and any existing
character from the mcu can organically
come into the picture it won't feel like
a gratuitous cameo it feels like hey
even superheroes need legal help i just
love the possibilities of that uh and we
see a lot of them come through the doors
of the law firm no this confuses me
because like yesterday or two days ago
we had a quote that was like don't
expect too many cameos right now cat
cornrows like there's gonna be so many
cameos your balls are gonna blow up i
feel like it depends uh
well the balls are gonna blow through
your back
okay we know we're gonna see all these
other
like small characters that have been
shown in like the teasers and stuff i i
think it also is like it depends on the
person for someone like jessica gao
who's writing is probably like yeah
there's not that many but for a cat
who's uh just doing she-hulk she's
probably like yeah there's a lot of
people that come through here like ten
to one person might be a lot and the
same person might be like yeah it's true
and i feel like that's how i would
probably work in this room if or if i
was on set i'd be like yeah there's like
six people here that shocked my mind but
then i knew like that's also me working
in entertainment you guys
you guys it's time for our discussion
it's 3 30 pm
um it's 3 30 pm on the west coast what
time is it where you're at either way
our discussion is pretty heavy today and
i'm going to do this by myself you're
going to do it by yourself can you hand
me this can you hand me the sword you
just asked to do about yourself no no
i'm at this part you're going to move
this by yourself yeah you don't want to
hit him okay
after she yeah after she-hulk i can do
this by myself okay
nicely done need any of your freaking
helps
okay okay all right she did it by
yourself you did a good job this is
great this is beautiful you guys we're
wondering where steve rogers is yeah and
we're gonna do it with a little bit of
uh house of the dragon up in this so
where the hell is steve rogers you guys
since jennifer walters and hulk's
discussion disclosed whether or not
steve is alive um it was jen who
basically was like he's dead but hulk
was saying
present tense he basically isn't dead
right so we're trying to deduce and the
pepe sylvia uh always suddenly in
philadelphia away where could he
possibly be right now
so this sword i'm gonna use is like the
poking stick for whoever's talking to
point out their subject you're gonna
point a sword in it no we're gonna go
like this oh okay oh we're gonna go like
that so this pet and i also do want to
thank sam um our office coordinator who
is also an artist she went to school for
uh
for um
not drawing but for yeah yeah but she
she illustration illustration and she
she did all she did this and she's a
phenomenal artist and i love her so much
so who wants to go first where do they
think steve rogers could be i'll go
first okay go ahead i'll go first
i have to point the point it seems
dangerous it's okay i think our boy
cap is in a little house with peggy
uh
i think he's like in a different
timeline i don't think he i think he
came back gave this shield to sam wilson
and then left again i don't think he's
stuck around i think he's just in
another timeline you think he brought
peggy to another timeline uh no i think
he's in this this
timeline with peggy got it like him
going back and staying split it got it
uh and whatever you needed to get killed
off got killed off uh but that's where
he's hiding out i think he jumped back
over to say how do you do here's the
shield and i'm gonna leave again thanks
so much
uh that's what i think i think it's just
like hiding i agree too much with voss
and i agree that he's in space
i agree with he's in space i know that
it's a deep pool to be like he is in
space uh following the falcon in the
winter soldier where they're like oh
conspiracy theories thinks he's on the
moon watching us but i do think if
there's a place that you need to hide
and get away from and also just be alive
that that is where you go you can't be
in like new jersey people you're captain
america you can't be
on the moon though is that does that
count for you as in space uh yes
they come out
i'm leaning more of the space station
with fury i like the idea of him still
working with fury and still being higher
up past the moon you think he's by
himself on the moon
you want him on the moon so bad well
that's why i'm just wondering if he's on
the moon is he by himself is he yeah he
has to be right oh i think he's with him
he's gotta have something yeah
um he could be doing umbrella academy
where he's just studying
okay
steve rogers has been once again
betrayed
by the elements and he's frozen
underneath the capitol building
you think they got him and they dragged
steve down
in an alternate timeline when he was
still young and they said i need you and
they tricked him and they froze him oh
they buy like another steve over that's
right all right i like that maybe he's
in the lincoln monument i think it's a
combination of in a house with peggy but
in dc oh
cap would want to feel like he's helping
and i think he'd want to have his finger
open
so i think he'd be like with her i don't
think he leaves peggy ever again he's
served his time yeah a soldier fights
you know a certain amount of time and
then they get to like you know walk into
the sunset i think sunset but feeling
like he's helping in some way but also
not having to like he's earned not
having to deal with all this so i'm
putting these two together i don't think
he's with pick if you think he's working
in dc do you think he's working like the
ground i just don't think that he's like
the guy in the chair i think he's asleep
they're clearly i just think washington
dc is like so grounded wouldn't there be
something higher than washington dc that
he'd be working i think he's going to be
organizing what the alternative to the
thunderbolts is like i think he's
running a nick fury s ground game of
taking care of tactical stuff okay he's
still a captain but he's doing it
without having to be in the field so let
me ask you guys you guys don't think
he's in wakanda no
no i don't not one bit why does it feel
like peggy and him
though they're just repeating what if uh
peggy's dead
well then i'm sad for him again
he's earned this i want the happily
ever if you look at like they planted
seeds in agent carter that like we never
saw the husband
like there's there's things to make us
believe that she went that he went back
and like lived that whole timeline with
her i just think he lived it and then
she dies but then he's old and then he
died yeah i think he outlives her maybe
about two years ago i know women live
longer than men okay i see your theory
but when i die before you what's gonna
happen uh i think you'll be sad for a
day oh whatever oh whatever i think okay
i like the idea of him coming okay so if
wakanda does lead us to doom which leads
us to secret wars
i i like in planting seeds i would like
him to be here a little bit but that is
just me that could be me because i just
like wakanda and i want to see what he's
doing there and how he'd be handling it
because bucky basically lived here for a
minute so maybe this is the situation
i got a hot take i hope we never see
steve rogers again wow
i hope i hope we like because it's a
perfect ending like that's the it'll
only some people
fans a lot of fans are really upset with
the mystery but i i think that's the
perfect end for the story the arc of his
journey if you undermine that then
you've negated the the landing
i guess it just depends on how you can
see that
yeah and how the landing goes and tony
dying at him not and then whatever after
herself was selfish what about like him
coming back in like uh flashbacks like
what if there was like a movie that
takes place way before it would
undermine the last moment if we see
chris evans cap again it'll feel like it
i don't want to be that person but
that's kind of how i felt with black
widow i was like i didn't really care
now
my hot take is like let chris rest okay
i agree but we don't know if they're
gonna shake it up and they're gonna
bring back robert downey jr for like
secret wars or him for super wars or
what have you but i do hope what we do
what we believe it um okay and then
power broker is a scroll so he's not
with her you don't think of the power
broker no i mean it would be wild for
him to go live out with peggy and then
come back and live out with shannon for
a little bit
just yes he loves the carters yeah he
loves the carters we don't think he's in
a different timeline altogether that's
what i think is that he's hiding with
peggy in like a different way
so he's combo here i'm combo here okay
and if he comes back it better be his
human torch or luke from scott pilgrim
never mind i'm erasing this right this
second
in that timeline he's in it's like all
this time when he's an actor as this guy
is not another teen movie scott phillips
perfect i like this one a lot the
different timeline with peggy still i
also like the different timeline at the
top but it can go to any of these he
could be doing any of these in this
yeah um we don't think okay so i we put
bucky hulk and sam wilson here because
do we think that they would know where
he is
sam sam would be the only one i think
maybe knows i think bucky might i think
bucky would like want to visit because
also he seemed to trust bucky as he like
you know hey i'm gonna entrust this with
sam we have a little moment i'm gonna
tell you where i'm at right i get the
idea of hulk knowing like bruce knowing
just because like he's like the last
i mean living avenger hanging out on
earth like obviously clint barnes around
but he's not really he's trying to be
out the game right like bruce is still a
part of everything
and it it's important for bruce to know
where he is
and i think he trusts bruce enough to
tell him but i out of all those three i
would not trust bruce the most
especially now that we saw him in
she-hulk just straight up disclosing a
little bit too much information
or that was uh to throw him off the
trail yeah that could have been a little
bit of a that could have been
misinformation planted misinformation so
in our hearts so as a unit where do we
think we lean the most frozen under the
capitol building okay
i think he's in a house
with peggy yeah i think that's what he
is i believe do we think where is the
house i think dc but maybe at a
different timeline for continuity yeah
but either way i think he's earned it
yeah i don't think he could be dc seems
to
i think he's in oregon
oh that's the thing that's my one thing
i know that he doesn't look like himself
at the end of end game but it's still
like people notice a man that's aged in
their older face so that's why i just
don't think he's either in a different
timeline or he's just not in america or
not even america the earth because i
just people would recognize him yeah i
think that's too hard he'd have to get
like facial reconstruction surgery he's
a spy he's a but i do agree that he's
living with peggy yeah i can agree with
that where's our second
what's our second choice i mean
it's not really on the board i guess
like in our hearts i think he he could
legitimately just be dead yeah no yeah
100 percent he could have like handed
off the shield and then been like god
damn it
i'm coming
for you
over here
in front of the camera oh no dude i'm in
front of the camera brandon okay
i honestly think that could be our
second choice he's just dead yeah i mean
i don't think he lived a lot longer
after the timeline where we saw him
older i don't think like that was the
expectation oh no no no no
no oh no he's in the sydney opera house
but i do think from like what 30 say 33
to like 90 when we met him again i think
he was 60 years he was with peggy yeah
jeremy like from this point to where we
saw him in an end game i think he was
with peggy i'm sorry
when judgment comes
i'm sorry i shouldn't have engaged with
you no that's yeah i agree you said 60
years they were aware yeah i'm saying if
he was say he's in his 30s here and we
saw him in his 90s here i do think
between here and here was here yeah i
think he's just vibing yeah 100
so he might be he might be in our 616
timeline here but i think the journey to
there is there it's just the normal yeah
yeah the american dream yeah okay
perfect tv dinner table
it's got to be more than even just like
six years
more than six years i don't think it
caught up with them that fat i mean
isaiah bradley looked pretty old that's
true he was still very strong he looked
old but he had also been like
experimented on right not treated well
and was never at any point frozen he
looks like she was straight out right so
like he was so old and feeble and then
game
uh i just don't the death came right
after like you said three days after
he he must have been living for like 200
years somewhere like a long time out of
the ice unless it catches up as you get
older and all of a sudden it just like
shuts down yeah maybe maybe him and
peggy developed a serum to make a mage
normally
oh you're not on camera everyone stopped
so i'll say something
the screenwriters and the
producers have different answers for
that question yeah the numbers that i've
heard thrown around is 113 and
116. oh so all right i'm wearing that so
for over 100 years i think he was he was
playing house
and then he died okay i can stand by
that but i think our second option is
definitely just the different timeline
in general uh actually no maybe not
because it's like that means that in 616
he got thrown into a different timeline
that's what we're saying well the
timeline would have split because of
such a major event yeah
he's frozen so it's not like there's
gonna be two of them
because he's gonna be frozen like the
the that timeline him is tucked away one
stupid time and then perfect so we have
our
him going to home and getting it on to
dine immediately
we have him branching off another
timeline and starting a new timeline
and i will give tommy the third option
of he is buried underneath washington dc
frozen uh i think it's actually very
interesting that we don't think it's
anything to do with madrapore no and we
don't think it has anything to do with
wakanda
but i like where our ideas went thank
you for joining my teacher
what a ted talk wonderful wonderful
i accept these terms uh people in the
chat have their own opinions of where
he's hiding
uh frank girl saying he was in brooklyn
you think he goes back to brooklyn does
he own property oh maybe did he own his
parents house
elijah bowser saying peggy and steve had
kids and
they have his super strength and he's
training them up to fight with uh fight
the scrolls and nick fury what are those
poles saying i don't know because this
is my thing too is like if he's gonna
outlive peggy by a lot it's gonna be
tough plus what if they're together for
five years and they're like this this
does not oh we actually don't like each
other
he would have made it work he would have
made it work because he doesn't believe
in divorce azalea rivera saying old cap
is chill
in a nursing home in washington dc oh if
he's just stuck in a nurse he's just
he's like i'm a captain i was captain
america sure you were sure
setting in a super chat for superhero
nursing home now that's the show doing
like golden girls oh thank you for being
a friend for for superhumans that would
be a lot of fun uh yes then thank you
mgz pnw pacific northwest for having us
uh
for sending in your super chat as a
reminder every hundred dollars we get in
super chats today we're gonna be hawking
out
on a
uh topic from the bucket uh so send in
the super chats i need a fan we also had
some uh
uh
polls we've ran on the chat today that
have been great uh what we got which
avengers actors would you like to see in
a minute max will be 39 saints color
johansen we're heating up here in our
secret world i know dang well we didn't
just get hot from standing it was
ruby uh
uh we also asked which jason memorial
you are most excited for aquaman
i think season seven of c you're gonna
have to wait a whole other year for that
movie yeah didn't watch didn't watch the
at all no neither but for some reason
it's been on for 25 years didn't catch
it missed it didn't catch it uh and we
also asked do you think loki is the best
disney plus series with 58 percent
saying yes
uh that could be confirmation
i don't know we we're getting the vapors
uh it's hot here you guys are just so
beautiful
it makes it hot uh uh but you know
what's even hotter than the temperature
yeah our sponsors that's right it's
important to get a good night's sleep
everyone and nothing helps you achieve
the perfect night's sleep like the right
mattress that's why we want to thank our
friends at helix sleep for sponsoring
the break room all this week helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete it matches your body type
and sleep preference to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else i mean
i've gone off on this if you have a kid
you should buy them a mattress
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for you
the way and the way you sleep
everybody's unique well some people are
remarkably similar and basic
but helix knows that so they have
several different mattresses models
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses i like a
soft mattress i just sink into it's like
a hug i like a hug from my mattress
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot like i do mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers i
love my helix mattress i've had it for a
couple of years i sleep like an angel
every night
everybody i invite about 15 people to
watch me sleep every night and they
always say you look so peaceful so
let's take the quiz
in order to match your match to the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't even need to
go to the mattress store ever again just
go to helixsleep.com break room take
their two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you with a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they got a 10-year warranty
that's a decade baby that's two olympics
and a half
and you have to try it out for 100
nights risk-free 100 nights
i mean play your cards right that's
several lovers they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will you'll never see those people again
after they drop it off because you're
gonna love this mattress helix even has
financing options and flexible payment
plans so great night sleep is never far
away helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixlee.com
break room
now
we also want to thank our other sponsor
better help keeping your mind happy and
healthy is important so why not invest
some time money and energy in doing just
that i am currently using better health
and i gotta say you think this is bad
imagine me without better help okay it'd
be a real nightmare for people so thank
you better help you're keeping my
interpersonal relationships in the
office intact you're teaching me coping
mechanisms i'm learning about attachment
styles
it turns out i'm a little bit of an
avoidant detachment person better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions and because it's online you can
do it from wherever you feel most
comfortable me i like to go in the
closet put a towel over my head and just
make it so dark and safe they even have
an option to have the camera turned off
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to plus it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy
and here's what's really nice
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
break room that's better h-e-l-p
com slash
break room
uh
thank you thank you thank you to our
sponsors this week uh we did go over our
chat redemption uh they couldn't decide
on the chat tommy and jess you both get
to hulk out on a random should we go
back and forth yeah yeah
thank you to our super chatters we have
two mics yeah like there's another one
uh right there on the bottles thank you
the bottles you know what i'm talking
about
thank you to all of our super chatters
like elijah browser he asked what if uh
what if camp is a different actor
because he is normal doesn't want to be
seen and can't die so easily so he's
still on earth waiting for the next
threat to emerge ah oh well like there's
another cap i like that
i also like our super chat from
graveyard uh who says where can i buy
tickets to watch tommy sleep
you don't have to buy a ticket you just
gotta come to my house
just open the door walk in all right
time to hulk out on mascots okay hulk
afraid of san diego chicken oh
oh hulk hates the orange one from
philadelphia
hulk like gritty when hulk was boy he
thought mickey mouse was real not person
in mickey mouse costume devastated to
find out what are you talking about
talk has made grave error
hulk looks at gritty and is confused
sexually is it not grimace why is it
orange its eyes move in different
directions just like hulks oh hulk think
grimace should be executed hopefully
grimace should go to electric chair for
abominations against
god and nature oh hope just wants to
remind you guys that oh grimace is
actually a taste bud on your tongue
yeah grimace is not a chicken nugget he
is not a nuggy nugs he is actually a
tasty tasty white bud why did the the
anthropomorphic uh hamburgers wear
clothes but not gremlins
wouldn't fit in the suit
have corkscrew penis
that unfurl out with a house did you
know
just like the duck the
the corporal penis once it's in it's
really hard to get out oh that's right
yeah that's why you shouldn't have sex
with dogs oh okay i try not to
oh that you do avoid sleeping with ducks
at all costs hulk in relationship with
daisy duck
a mascot for a while hulk file for
divorce
california no fault devorah state hulk
feel alone do you know do you know
daisy's uh niece's names you know
there's huey dewey and louie there's the
female versions they have names too i
feel like you're just trying to get in
this uh hulk wants to know i guess
you want to take the mic from hulk no
you want this mic you want a spit hot
fire like hulk does hulks have a
favorite mascara hope favorite mascot is
paws detroit tigers mascot or billy the
buffalo from buffalo bills this sounds
biased
oh this i like oh i watch sports all the
time hulk loves sports and his favorite
sport is probably basketball the chicago
bulls benny the ball yeah that's a team
and whole gloves or the sock from the
red sox
the white song the green monster or
what's what's the weather that's not
really nice no it's a fenway like green
monster is the wall and then the the
fenway [ __ ] fanatic sorry for the f
word uh which one casual uh
oh no
the boston red sox have a confusing man
if you know what the mascot is of the
boston red sox please call him i think
his name is
aren't you rapey jack what is it
all right
that's enough of that we gotta get to
mandatory fun before it's time to leave
it's time for mandatory fun
that's right we've been having too much
uh free fun yeah we haven't had a lot of
fun that has been obligated
now mandatory fun is when i get my three
and jesus jesus christ how do you say
austria oh wally yes of course daschle
just took a dive i saw it wow
oh wally yeah
all right hit the graphic again
that's enough boston you've been heard
you've been heard boston you've been
knowledgeable boston 300 years of racism
ain't going away overnight all right
sam adams is a great brewery listen i
love the city of boston okay we also
only talk crap on boston because empty
is also from boston yeah
i thought we were against miami if
you're watching the show call in please
thanks so much
you know what they call a boston prom
dress a garbage bag now it's week two
what
happens it's week two of our sheep help
fantasy prediction and let's be real
i'm doing pretty bad i think i have zero
you have zero points because you love to
keep pointing
why do i i don't love to point it out i
want to do better but like all classic
comeback stories it only takes one week
to change momentum
so
here's our picks for this week i have
three questions for us
we're just gonna go around and give our
answer do we think she-hulk will team up
with someone this week
and if so who like to like a fight no
like teamwork
yeah
i i don't think she's gonna team up with
anybody yeah i'm saying no one okay
she's on her own
okay she's free
jessica
okay got it
all right
and i literally was like what do i say
this seems like uh uh that fixes him
like very uncomfortable well i said like
a whole it was confusing i'm going to
say jessica jones i think we started
oh my goodness folded in pre-daredevil
episode two swinging for it kristen
ritter
she's tall she's excellent i she's tall
she's excellent i think they're i think
she's going to team up with nikki an
unpowered being oh her friend i think
mickey's gonna think he's gonna assist
her like throw her something i think
that's a fair bet i think nicki's a
witch and i stand by it
i think she's going to be in agatha's
series
i also think i don't think there's a
team up i agree with brandon i don't
think there's gonna be a team
first off i typed it out first but i
don't you didn't give it first f's in
the chat for two people answering the
same thing now
the second
uh prompt the second thing we're going
to wager on here is crazy emil blonsky
predictions we're all going to predict
something that emil banks is going to do
but it's not just like sit down and talk
or whatever be in prison he's gonna
breathe he's gonna do something crazy
yeah okay that would be a safe bet i i
think he's gonna break down in tears
uh like begging for his life i like
basically like please get me out of here
okay
i'm gonna go with uh more poetry okay
and perhaps uh either a reference to or
a dance oh no that's funny i also said
he was going to dance
dancing because i also said he was going
to break down and cry
wow
no i didn't i said he's gonna he's gonna
break off his clothes break off his
clothes break it out
all right and now finally we have uh um
we're gonna do a little over under here
amount of times that jennifer
is going to hulk out
like settings
yeah she's going to turn into she-hulk
we're setting it at three and a half i'm
going under
three and a half yeah i think i'm going
over i'm going over for sure you go
under under okay so if it's three
two or one coy and i get the points if
it's four to infinity
you guys get those watches
now i think we're running a poll in the
chat you can pick one of us as a
to wage your bets on you did great last
week you picked jessica uh and she can i
see she cheated her way to ten points
last week uh would you as a chat get
those ten points as well so make sure to
answer that poll if it's in there
all 16 of you back there oh beautiful
we've got a great graphics department
working working real hard love you guys
uh we had some other super chats we
should acknowledge today uh christian
cizine said do you think they'll
introduce a young aurora in wakanda
forever i don't know are we gonna get a
little wish
i would i wouldn't i would go crazy yeah
there's just so much things happening
that i wouldn't want and i think they
did they thought about this too with
like miss marvel they were like we
didn't want to bring in such a big
character when we're focusing on this
storyline right here and that's a big
thing that would take away yeah but i
would i would i would literally give my
right arm for that i would like a young
aurora i just don't think we should do
it black panther like i think we should
get a origin story with her i think that
like i can't think of a more cinematic
x-men that deserves around i think they
should call it sprinkles it's like a
role in everything
but i would i would watch her origin
film a million times to anyone else's no
offense no for the rest of the time
it's just because millionaires so much
she's so cinematic i didn't see it and i
want it and then the whole goddess
commentary playing with the mutant fear
and then also like her being
claustrophobic as a child and like her
flying to counteract her feelings across
from phobia it's such a beautiful arc of
like her accepting flight as a way to
accept like her freedom from
claustrophobia we need that journey
which we've never gotten
i'm not pearl mudder i'm not jessica
stealing from people i want to see her
little her little little fingers going
around stealing from people and then we
can bring a moon knight maybe but i just
want our origins
i want to drag
rematches
brandon said he only wants jubilee
origins and that's only one jubilee
there's going to be a jubilee trilogy
setting up the main jubilee universe yes
jcu we also got a super jefferson ron
sortino saying i think kappa is living
his days in the alternate timeline with
peggy but
i think evan's cameo as a skrull taking
his appearance could happen
folks they could do it those evils evil
mcu
uh jackson brody asking will peggy
carter ever return in live action mcu i
think so captain not as catholic or do
you think
yeah i think they're bringing captain
carter do you think like a peggy carter
i think captain's more likely and i
think like secret wars multiverse and
those kind of things you'd want that
what do you mean when you're saying
because she is because she what if she
just took off the suit right i know i
know what i'm saying i know what i'm
saying here oh look here i know
[Music]
uh bring back bring back old i was
rewatching where soldier when she's old
and like she has that weird moment of
like almost dementia at the very end
which is very upsetting i was like oh
yeah let's dig into that
i know
i'm sorry apparently it's a deleted team
from first of all
they filmed that and they kept it that
makes way more sexy
um i like that i like that marvel magic
uh edgar padilla saying i'm surprised no
one mentions scott lang essentially
creating immortality with his time
travel attempt to reverse his own age
did a benjamin button maybe cap could
have made use of that i mean the
selfishness of like cap who already gets
to live so long just being like
a god
i like that version
of bringing back a cap that is almost
like okay oh yeah he's become so
obsessed he's become a mortise kevin
feige here's a free one for you captain
america becomes a mortise how crazy is
that
he gets stuck at that time
he becomes luke skywalker now he's the
bad one uh i mean you gotta find all the
captain america books yeah that's it and
then the ghost of bucky has to be like
this sounds like a nice first half
i gotta teach so bad
captain america is hiding from the
avengers and just wants to retire stop
calling him he's begging them please do
it
ron certino
i'm so busy fighting brandon i've lost
track of what he said ten dollars thank
you chrissy
are you betting on jessica's uh you said
koi smells like a fart yeah
to thank you guys for tuning in on your
wednesday you could be anywhere during
this hour but you were right here we
appreciate it and go ahead and hit that
like button join the discord where you
can submit your clip of the week and
your voicemails we forgot to do last
week's clip of the week but maybe we'll
do two this lesson
don't forget to watch she-hulk uh before
our next episode of the break room
because we will be talking about it
spoiling it and everything uh we weren't
supposed to talk about andor today but
apologies to android oh
damn it uh we thank you all for joining
us we can't wait to see here tomorrow uh
rodrigo vargas needs some mandatory
sadness uh the show's ending boohoo baby